hi everyone this is Professor M science
and this video is part of our series on
Maths for Science and Engineering this
video covers separable differential
equations luckily these are some of the
easiest differential equations to solve
all you really need to know is how to
evaluate an integral and in this video
we will learn why that is the case
despite their Simplicity separable
differential equations feature in some
really interesting areas from beautiful
geometric forms to exponential growth
which is very important in many branches
of science and engineering and even in
areas like economics so let's
go in this video we consider separable
first order ordinary differential
equations I know the name is a bit of a
mouthful um so what do we mean by that
if we check a textbook what we find is
that they are equations that can be
written as the derivative of y with
respect to x equal to f ofx * G of
Y but let's dissect what each of the
terms in the name
means the equation is first order
because the highest derivative that
appears in the equation is a first
derivative and it is an ordinary
differential equation because there are
no partial derivatives the family of
first order ordinary differential
equations is vast and in this video we
will explore a small but important
subset of such equations which are
called
separable now the key to identify a
separable equation is to figure out
whether it can be written in this form
where the right hand side is the product
of two functions f and g where the
function f only depends on X and the
function G only depends on y and the
name separable perhaps isn't really
obvious at this point but it will become
really clear later on in this
video so in practice how do we know if a
given differential equation is separable
what you need to do whenever you
encounter a first order ordinary
differential equation is to try standard
algebraic manipulations to see if you
can transform it to this form here if
you can then you have a separable
equation and don't worry if this task
looks a bit daunting because with enough
practice you'll become proficient at the
required
manipulations okay so now that we've
established notation when solving
differential equations our job will
always be the same to find y as a
function of X and in this video we will
cover how to find y as a function of X
for separable
equations but before we do that let's
see a few examples examples of separable
equations so that you get a feeling for
what they may look like we can have dydx
equal to - x over y by inspection we can
clearly see that on the right hand side
we have separate factors for x and y and
this demonstrates that we do have a
separable equation but to make this a
bit more concrete we can compare our
example to the general form up here and
we can identify the function f as equal
to Min - x and the function G as equal
to 1 /
y note that we could also choose F to be
X and then G would be - 1 / y either way
we clearly see that this example has the
general form of a separable
equation and before we move on let me
tell you that this differential equation
describes a circle centered at the
origin and you can find the detailed
solution of that in a separate video
that's Linked In the
description as a second example we can
write dydx equal Y and by inspection it
is again clear that this equation is
separable in fact the right hand side
only depends on Y and we don't have any
explicit function of X but just to make
this pedantically concrete in this case
the function f is equal to one because
there is no explicit X dependent while
the function g equals
y and again we can clearly see that this
example has a general form of a
separable
equation this equation describes
exponential growth and we will solve it
in a moment but before we do that let's
discuss how to solve a general separable
first order
equation this is the general equation we
want to solve
if we can find a general strategy to
solve equations of this form we will be
able to apply it directly to any
separable equation we
encounter we will first solve it by
using an algebraic trick that simplifies
things
enormously so what's that trick let's
copy down our equation
again and the trick will be to consider
the derivative dydx as a standard ratio
of the quantity dy over the quantity
DX and I know a lot of you are probably
gasping disapprovingly how dare we do
this don't worry there's a reason why we
can do it and bear with me and I will
explain why a bit
later what's important for now is that
treating the derivative as a ratio we
can manipulate this expression such that
we move all quantities that depend on y
to the left hand side so G is now
dividing and all quantities that depend
on X to the right hand side so that DX
is now
multiplying what we have just done is
called separation of variables we have
separated the Y's and the X's by moving
all the Y's to one side and all the X's
to the other side we can do this for any
equation of this form and for this
reason an equation like this is called a
separable
equation once we've separated the
variables like this we can next
integrate both sides with an integral
over y on the left hand side and an
integral over X on the right hand
side evaluating these integrals will
give us an expression relating y and x
and therefore we will have the solution
to our differential equation we'll look
at an example of solving a separable
equation like this in a moment but the
discussion here is general and applies
to any differential equation of this
form up here now there's a small caveat
to this discussion finding a solution
requires being able to evaluate these
two
integrals while many important
differential equations in science and
engineering lead to integrals that we
can indeed solve explicitly there are
integrals for which this may be
difficult or even impossible so this is
just something to bear in mind and I
also haven't forgotten about that
mathematical justification for the
algebraic trick I promised earlier we
will discuss it at the end of the video
but first let's look at an example of
solving a separable differential
equation let's look at the example dydx
equals y first let's copy it down and
remember that what we discussed in the
previous slide is that we can solve
separable equations by taking all the
terms that depend on y to one side and
those that depend on x to the other next
we integrate the left hand side and we
also integrate the right hand
side let's start with the left hand side
this is one of the standard integrals
that you've likely encountered before
and it is equal to the natural logarithm
of Y and we also have an integration
constant
C1 so let's next consider the right hand
side this is again one of the easy
integrals and we get X plus an
integration constant
C2 we can now insert the first integral
into the left hand side and the second
integral into the right hand side and we
get that the natural logarithm of y + C1
is equal to x + C2 and we can rewrite
this as the logarithm of y equal to x +
C3 where C3 is a new constant made up of
C2 minus
C1 finally we can calculate the
exponential of both sides of this
function to get e to the power logarithm
of Y = to e^ x +
C3 remember that the exponential of a
natural logarithm just gives the
argument of the logarithm so we get y
here and remember that the exponential
of a sum is equal to the product of EXP
exponentials so that we get the
exponential of x times the exponential
of
C3 as C3 is just a constant the
exponential of C3 is just another
constant and we will call it
C overall we can write that the function
y of X is equal to C * the exponential
of X and this is our solution to the
differential equation at the
top we could just stop here as we have
now solved this differential equation
and also found that the solution takes
this
form and when you get to this point you
could ask yourself is this true or have
I made a mistake somewhere say in the
integration
steps there are two things that you can
do to convince yourself that the
solution you found is
correct the first thing we should do is
to try and insert the solution back into
the equation and to confirm that the
equation is obeyed so let's do it our
proposed solution is y equals c e to ^ x
and to confirm that this is a valid
solution we can evaluate the derivative
of y which explicitly gives us the
derivative with respect to X of this
solution remember that the derivative of
an exponential is equal to the
exponential and using this result and
remembering that c is just a constant we
get this expression for the derivative
of our
solution and now we see that this here
is simply the original function
y therefore we find that the derivative
of our proposed solution is indeed equal
to Y and this confirms that our solution
is
correct the second useful thing you can
do to check that your result makes sense
is to draw a graph of your solution
function and that's what we're going to
do
next on this pair of
axes the horizontal axis is the xaxis
and the vertical axis is the Y
AIS the solution of a differential
equation often involves one or more
constants in our case the C here what
this means is that this is a solution to
the differential equation for any value
that c may take to put it another way
that means that there is a whole family
of solutions to the differential
equation parameterized by the constant c
as C can take any value there is in fact
an infinite number of solutions to this
equation this means that for plotting
this solution we need to First make a
choice for the parameter C let's first
choose the simplest value C equals 0 in
this case our solution is Trivial as we
get y equals 0 and the plot of the
solution is this blue horizontal line on
the
x-axis does this solution make sense our
equation says that the slope of the
function is equal to the function itself
and indeed the slope of the constant
function zero is itself
zero now for positive values of c we
have a standard exponential function and
here I'm showing a few representative
values in green the darkest green
corresponds to a value of c equal to 0
.1 while this fifth green curve
corresponds to a value of c equal 1 and
as such the crossing point of this curve
with the vertical axis here corresponds
to a value of y equal
1 the exponential function grows
exponentially all the way from X coming
from minus infinity to X going to plus
infinity do these Solutions make sense
qualitatively we do indeed have that the
slope of the exponential function grows
with growing X we cannot assess the
precise relationship just by I but at
least the general form of the solution
is consistent with the equation we
have finally let's consider negative
values for C with a few examples shown
in red and orange in the diagram we
still have exponential functions but due
to the negative value of C they are
reflected about the horizontal axis
compared to the corresponding solutions
for positive C and I just want to
emphasize once more that any of these
functions is a valid solution to our
differential
equation we've now discussed how to
solve separable first order ordinary
differential equations which remember
take this
form if you're only interested in the
practicalities of solving these
equations we've already discussed the
separation of variable strategy and you
can stop watching right now but as
promised for those of you who are also
interested in a better justification for
the algebraic trick of treating the
derivative as a ratio then this is what
we will discuss for the rest of this
video Let's copy down our differential
equation once more and to make things as
clear as possible I'm including all
functional dependencies in this
expression for example I'm explicitly
writing G as a function of Y which in
turn is a function of X now I won't be
completely consistent as to whether I
keep all functional dependencies in I
will only do so when it can help me make
the discussion clearer but overall the
key point is to make sure that you
remember the relevant dependencies when
necessary so moving on WE rewrite this
equation by separating the f and g
functions but this time we don't play
any tricks on the derivative so we keep
the dydx together and also note that I'm
leaving some space to facilitate the
next step using up these spaces We Now
integrate both sides of the equation
with respect to X on the left hand side
and also with respect to X on the right
hand side to make progress let's define
a new function capital G of Y such that
its derivative with respect to Y is
equal to 1 over little G of Y y to put
it another way capital G of Y is the
anti-derivative of 1/ little G of Y
keeping this definition in mind we
consider the derivative of capital G
with respect to X and again I'm
including all functional dependencies in
this
expression Now using the chain rule we
first get the derivative of capital G
with respect to Y multiplied by the
derivative of y with respect to X
by the definition of capital G as the
anti-derivative of 1 over little G we
can insert this definition into this
term and we end up with this
expression let's copy down this latest
result and I'm switching the left and
right sides and also leaving spaces in
preparation for the next
step this next step is to integrate both
sides with respect to X starting with
the left hand size and then the right
hand side this integral in the right
hand side is now easy to evaluate and we
simply get the function capital G as
capital G is the anti-derivative of 1/
little G as defined on this line here
then we can rewrite our result as the
integral of 1 / G with respect to Y
overall we can see that this integral
over X is equal to this integral over Y
and inserting this result into the left
hand side of our original equation up
here we can conclude that the integral
of 1 / G with respect to Y is equal to
the integral of f with respect to
X and you can now probably see what
we've accomplished this is exactly the
same expression that we got earlier on
the in the video when we used the
algebraic trick of separating the Dy and
DX terms in the derivative but we've now
obtained this result without resorting
to that trick so this is our
justification for that separation of
variables trick that we use when solving
this class of differential
equations right so let's summarize
everything we've learned in this video
we have looked at separable first order
ordinary differential equations which
take this
form the solution involves two steps
first we separate the terms in the
equation by putting all y's on one side
and all x's on the other
side and second we integrate both sides
the left hand side with respect to
Y and the right hand side with respect
to X and with this strategy we can solve
any such equation and you can find links
to example Solutions in the
description you can check out additional
examples of separable equations in the
videos that are linked in the
description I really hope that you liked
the video and please
subscribe